foreign
[Music]
Ukraine
the setting for the largest military
conflict in Europe since the Second
World War
[Music]
[Applause]
Russia's assault Relentless from its
first incursion on February 24th
[Music]
it's very painful to see you my first
reaction was that probably
um I've just lost my country the country
I've borne in and it might happen that
my I may never ever come back there
[Applause]
Ukrainian Fighters defiantly resisting a
much larger and more powerful military
force
[Music]
the city is bombed
Villages destroyed
[Music]
strategic installations reduced to ashes
for weeks any efforts at a ceasefire
futile
humanitarian corridors Under Fire
both sides blaming the other
lives of millions transformed forever
the whole country is changing
someone who has lost their homes
Millions have
fled from Ukraine hundreds of thousands
are fighting
and that's I I can believe that any
other person wasn't Touched By by this
war
foreign
[Music]
by February of 2022 a massive Russian
forces are gathered at the border with
Ukraine
yet the assault catches many by surprise
I thought that it's it's possible that
Russia could invade Ukraine but I didn't
believe that it would be so like the
likeliest scenario and I thought that
they would somehow find a diplomatic
solution for what would for what was
going on
most of ukrainians didn't believe
Ukrainian government didn't do Ukrainian
intelligence you don't believe Ukrainian
military analysts didn't believe in The
full-scale Invasion we've all been very
surprised by the scale of this war not
so much by the brutality of it but in
Ukraine we really see the kind of war
that we thought would never happen again
which involves a lot of Tanks
A lot of bombing
um and it's it's something that hasn't
only surprised us I think it's a
surprise the Russian military too
but the roots of this conflict Run Deep
the seeds planted as far back as 1989
with the collapse of the Soviet Union
in the span of a few years Russia loses
much of its power and influence
[Applause]
many of the countries and regions it
once dominated Unshackled from moscow's
control
several Soviet republics claim
Independence including Ukraine
this new world order does not sit well
with the man who becomes Russia's new
president at the turn of the millennium
Vladimir Putin
um
it's a displeasure he's never reluctant
to voice
mail
foreign
this is really at the core of Russian
history
um and uh Putin would see himself as the
guardian of this his mission is not to
prevent NATO expansion in Eastern Europe
his mission is to restore Russian
imperial power in Eastern Europe soon
after the fall of the USSR several
Eastern Bloc Nations joined NATO as well
as one former Soviet Republic Estonia
however it seems It's Ukraine's
flirtations with the West that most
infuriate Putin Putin tonight uh
is
the main threat was Ukraine breaking
away determining its own fate without
Russia that was the real danger here and
of course that danger involves Ukraine
becoming part of NATO Ukraine becoming
part of the EU while attending a summit
of NATO leaders in Bucharest in 2008
Putin makes his views clear
ly
a party foreign
NATO continues to ignore Russia's
grievances promising Ukraine and Georgia
they would be welcome to join the
Western military Alliance
but in the future leaving both countries
militarily vulnerable with a powerful
and angry neighbor the neck actually
looks like did very irresponsible thing
they promised Ukraine to become a member
of NATO in Bucharest
uh but they never had any uh consensus
about issuing and membership action plan
for Ukraine and now it appears they have
never even desired to defend Ukraine and
that's what suppose NATO is
NATO is all about this it's about
defense of all the members if if you
were never going to defend Ukraine why
you then
Promise This Promise the member of them
the membership in NATO I think there is
a lot of uh responsibility here
to be to be borne by the NATO States
I think
um
there was a presumption on the basis of
what happened in the 1990s and 2000s
that NATO expansion would not be opposed
by Russia
um as in Russia would not be able to do
anything to stop it and I think this is
a fundamental error on on the part of
NATO's planners and they were warned
about this
in August of 2008 russian-backed
Fighters shell Georgian villagers from
South ossettia and aprasia to republics
internationally recognized as part of
Georgia
Russia however insists they're
independent
Georgia Fights Back its retaliation
immediately branded provocation by
Russia as well as by both Republics
after a few days of skirmishes Russian
forces invade supposedly on their behalf
after five days of heavy fighting
Georgian forces capitulate
a victory for Russia a strong message
sent to Ukraine Russia laid down a kind
of warning if you like in the form of
the uh the war with Georgia
that this country would not be allowed
to join NATO and there was a threat to
its Integrity if that course was pursued
it was absolutely pivotal
um in Georgia the pretext was that
Georgia oppressed its minorities in the
North
so what Putin's wore there relied on was
that he could frame these two Northern
provinces of Georgia as being under
attack as the people there being
oppressed by Georgian nationalists which
is exactly the same as we can see as
we've been seeing in Ukraine with the
donbass region the succession Ukrainian
president's post-independence
different agendas
some seek closer tires with Moscow
others integration with the EU and NATO
most plagued by corruption
Ukraine has been genuinely pulled in
different directions
both economically and strategically both
the western parts of the country have
many more ties
towards the West they have much more of
a strong interest in joining the EU the
Eastern parts of the country are much
more closely integrated with Russia
economically demographically they have
much more of an interest in maintaining
close ties with Russia in parts of
Ukraine's East at powerful Russian
minority is determined to strengthen
links to what they regard as their
motherland
the region also has strong historical
ties to Russia bonds not lost on Putin
it is
uh
foreign
historical narratives at play there
Ukraine holds a special position in in
Putin's thinking for Putin
um you could let Georgia go you could
let the politics go you could even let
Kazakhstan go but you couldn't let go of
Ukraine with a population that speaks
Eastern Slavic languages which he
regards as just dialects of Russian
Victor Yanukovych elected Ukrainian
president in 2010 puts his predecessor's
efforts to join NATO on hold
instead he looks East to build a
stronger alliance with Moscow
he renews Russia's lease of a naval base
in Crimea in exchange for cheaper gas
but at the same time he pursues an
association agreement with the European
Union
even this is a step too far for Russia
Moscow exerts great economic pressure on
Kiev to derail the agreement and offers
Ukraine a much needed multi-billion
dollar loan with attractive terms
in late 2013 Yanukovych accepts Russia's
deal and shelves the EU agreement
within days demonstrators take to the
streets to voice their disapproval
the euromaidan protests
authorities intervene with brutal force
protesters respond by taking up arms
foreign
[Music]
quickly spirals out of control
within an already divided nation
violence escalates even further as a
faction of Hardcore nationalists the
ones President Putin refers to as Nazis
gets involved
they're determined to remove all ethnic
Russians and pro-russian ukrainians from
the country
in mid-February after months of mounting
violence Yanukovych flees the country
for Russia
on February 22nd the Ukrainian
Parliament votes unanimously to remove
him from his post
and Western eyes a successful popular
revolution that Russia sees it very
differently Russian government saw the
euromattan revolution as a coup d'etat
that was exploited by the United States
they didn't see the posterior McDon
Ukrainian government as some as kind of
like a sovereign government they started
increasingly seeing the Ukrainian
government as a puppet
of the United States this was a huge
simplification of what happened but if
you ask about how Putin made sin he may
claim that Ukraine has actually been
captured by the
radical nationalist forces by the United
States and now he's
allegedly liberating Ukraine from the
Hostile forces the Kremlin doesn't
really believe that
genuine popular movements exist
um it thinks that all of these things
are are you know
puppets manipulated either by the CIA or
by someone else in a way the maidan is
really the outcome of a much longer
polarization in Ukraine that's been
gradually unfolding and intensifying
over the past 20 years barely a few days
after janakov
what is the invasion of the Crimean
Peninsula an area on the Black Sea in
Ukraine South where military Skirmish
has reached for years in early March of
2014.
within a month Russia annexes Crimea at
the same time Moscow also supports armed
separatist Fighters and the donets and
Lohan's regions in eastern Ukraine
this fighting in the dombas ignites into
a full military confrontation between
the Ukrainian and Russian military as
well as various armed militia groups
several efforts of the ceasefire fail
agreements where greater autonomy is
granted to the region ignored
oh yeah
we see this now in hindsight as a kind
of dress rehearsal for what is happening
now that you know that the annexation of
Crimea the the the Russian fermenting of
separatism in the donbass those were in
a were an early version of this same
impulse which was put in saying to the
world I am willing to tear Ukraine apart
to stop the West getting it the fighting
in the donbass drags on
by the end of 2021 it claims more than
13 000 lives
all the while Russian troops amass in
huge numbers along the eastern border
with Ukraine
Moscow claims these troop movements are
merely military exercises while at the
same time warning the West time is
running out for a negotiated settlement
the world watches on fearing the worst
while hoping it's simply Russia flexing
its muscles
on February 24 2022 a full-scale
military Invasion begins
uh
foreign
the Russian invasion is Relentless and
seemingly indiscriminate
cities throughout the Border areas
besieged by persistent bombing and
mortifier
while Russia claims not to be targeting
residential areas
homes schools and even hospitals are hit
repeatedly
Moscow focuses its strongest offensive
on strategic cities along the Black Sea
Coast
[Music]
in Carson and Maria pool residents
completely besieged
trapped under an endless barrage of
missile and aerial attacks
after less than a month of fighting the
death troll estimated to be well over 5
000 civilians in mariapol alone
many of them children
[Music]
same time the Russian army has opened
France along Ukraine's northern border
while trying to move ever closer to the
capital Kiev
[Music]
Millions desperately flee the war
mostly women children and the elderly
men of fighting age volunteer
or made to stay and take part in the
fighting
Ukraine puts up a strong opposition
one seemingly led by Ukraine's President
Vladimir zelensky at the leader
the media Savvy leader posts frequent
daily videos calling for the nation to
stand up to the aggressor
his message also seen and heard
throughout the world making him the face
of Ukraine's resistance
despite facing a much larger and better
equipped Russian military force that
resistance proves very effective
stalling Russia's advance and on several
fronts pushing them back
their Retreat uncovers the Carnage
Russian forces leave behind corpses of
civilians strewn throughout residential
areas
and a legacy of landmines and unexploded
Ordnance to make the eventual return
home a dangerous Endeavor
um
uh Sila is called it is
[Music]
the West responds to the Russian
invasion with hard-hitting sanctions
hoping to [__] the Russian economy
and isolate Moscow on the international
stage
with an immediate hard-hitting effect in
coordination with allies and like-minded
partners the UK is a Nancy the largest
and most severe package of the of
economic sanctions that Russia has ever
seen
NATO countries have given financial
support as well as Weaponry to Ukraine
but fall short of direct involvement in
the war
its leaders fearing this would further
increase hostilities to dangerous levels
we will not fight a war against Russia
in Ukraine
direct confrontation between NATO and
Russia is World War III
something we must strive to prevent in
terms of the economic sanctions
themselves it will probably have a huge
impact on Russia in the long term not
right now it will not [__] the
Russian military that the Russian war
effort but in the long run it will lead
to a geopolitical shift
an economic shift in the global economy
often of unprecedented scale but that
would probably take years or even
decades it will not change it will not
determine the war the course of the war
foreign
Christian
long-term damage to Russia's economy and
international standing May well benefit
the West's interests
a weakened Russian military leaving it
vulnerable and more pliant to the
demands of its emboldened opponents
it could well increase Russia's Reliance
on China who have yet to condemn The
Invasion for China this was an
attractive War to support because they
were hoping that Russia would win this
war quickly thus weakening Europe
weakening the NATO and in turn thus
strengthening China it doesn't look like
this is happening because it's it's
strengthening NATO's resolve to respond
differently in the future
the war may be redefining the world's
geopolitical map
Ukraine the latest setting for the
endless power struggles between east and
west
many worry Vladimir Putin is as
uncompromising as he is determined and
there is no telling how far he is
willing to go
he may never accept that his
miscalculated the consequences of this
invasion
now we are in the moment when the
nuclear war is uh is probably the
likeliest since perhaps the 1960s but we
also understand that in the final
instance this would be put in who
could decide and if feeling that he is
losing in Ukraine he would be even more
eager to Blackmail the whole world maybe
that's his final plan is
while the interests of various countries
are playing out through this war
foreign
the people of Ukraine are caught in the
middle
and continue to pay the highest price
[Music]